this is Startalk do you have a cosmic
query someone write this query I
[Music]
wouldn't ask I would ask the one I asked
you on the show but unfortunately Aaron
yes then on the show or can I ask that
again okay because that is the one I'm
really concerned what's that mean what
we had a look to Ranger out here that
made it look like the world is coming to
an end
yeah and I don't think it's entirely
unfeasible that that kind of a drought
given the calamity of climate change
could happen in my lifetime you know
what I want to happen here's what here's
my so this that's not a question on an
observation what's the nearest place I
think it's not about finding another
planet I think it's about becoming
masters at geoengineering think about it
volcano we run away from volcanoes we
know how to tap a keg let's tap the
volcano take the pressure out so it
doesn't explode use the thermal energy
to drive the power needs of a city
the Hurricanes we run away from
hurricanes we're not there yet but think
of know imagine if we controlled by the
energy of the earth oh my gosh then we
can we can control where rains how much
it rains and meet with just these
scurrying scared things and we're so
many more away from from getting to
anywhere in the universe yes we are
anywhere anywhere anywhere I mean I
remember Bush used to talk about how we
have to put a base on the moon you know
so we can get to Mars
I understood you know there was no
gravity on the moon so let's grab it
yeah yeah no it's it's like there's no
air no water where the water you doesn't
take restaurants I used to joke about
restaurants on the moon they'd be fines
if they'd have no atmosphere I can make
a joke sometimes
no bill you could squirt about my vest
today
he was like getting on the case of my
best and but he but he's played with me
on it here's the other question I have
was there please do another season that
cosmos oh yeah we're working on there
we're trying to see thanks for that
endorsement one of my favorite shows
that was ever on television whenever
people talk about you have to see
Breaking Bad you have to see the rock
you have to see that I'm like no no no
you have to see cosmos yeah and you're
friends with Andrea and of course Seth
MacFarlane yeah everybody it was just
such an amazing show and I always say to
people watch that show and you'll
understand that like 12 to 20 people in
the world thought of everything great
that the other billion is just applause
yes okay so without like that's more
because every episode highlighted is a
person is this whole chunks of
civilization emanated from those
creativity without that very top point
and thought of everything the rest of it
would be wiping it would still be
alright this is for a start or this is
Startalk behind the scenes after a job
that convinced me okay no it's good ad
on your chart yeah excellent thanks Mara
thanks for being against I'll start
talking this is Startalk
[Music]